[موسيقى]
نغير الظروف
بس بيتنا نهونها
انت ما بيدك تشفي اي شخص مريض
بس بايدك تكون موجود فوق راسها بكل لحظه
راح يقعد خايف نص الليل
بايدك تسمعه
بيدك تخليه يحكي لحد ما يتطمن بايدك
تسويله للاشياء اللي يحبها بايدك تنطيه
الاكلات اللي يحبها
وبدك تكون يمه دائما
احنا لما نحب او لما نفرح نروح اكثر شخص
نحبه
ولما نحلم
نروح الوالدنا
ولما نخاف
هذه قبل كنا نخاف هسه كبرنا بعد عيب نخاف
لما نخاف نروح لامنا
بس لما نوصل لمرحله كل عظامنا ما تخلينا
نوقف على حالنا هنا النقطه الوحيده اللي
نحتاج نسويها انه احنا نامن
اول ما بدا المشروع عشان عباره عن كرفان
صغير
هل كرفان بمئات الاطفال المصابين بالسرطان
كنا كل مره يصاب طفل جديد يجمعون الاطفال
على الباب شنو نلعب لعبه صغيره يوقفون
ويصيحون نقنق
هنانا كنا نعرف انه اكو طفل جديد وصاب
بالسرطان واكو حرب جديده جاي تنتظرنا
هالمره لما ندق الباب
ما شان باب الاكاديميه
كان باب بيتنا
لما رحت اخذ التقارير من الطبيب قال لي
جمله واحده قال لي تالا رب العالمين يمنح
اقوى المعارك الى اقوى جنوده وانت اقواهم
هذه الجمله لطبيب نفسها قايل لي اياها
لاكثر من 200 مره بكل مره ينطيني تقرير
احد المحاربين طلعت ادور على رب العالمين
بكل مكان دورتها بالكنائس بالجوامع
بالمواكب بالمناظر الي دائما تصدح
بالاصوات ما لقيته
دورته بكل مكان بس نسيت انه انا ادور
بداخلي
اول سؤال سالته قلت لك ليش احنا بالبصراوي
لما نعاتب نقول قلت له ليش
انت خليتني مسؤوله عن الاف الاطفال
لما الكل اقتنع انه انا اقوى جنودك بس ليش
انت صدقت بهالشي
انا اعرف شلون ممكن اكون ام شلون كل ام
ممكن تضم اطفالها تحكي لهم قصه ليلى
والذيب الذيب اللي بدا ياكل شعره وبدا
ياكل او رته شلون ممكن يجي القطار من بعيد
يقنع انه هو ياكل
شلون يضم راسه عندي بكل مره يحاول الممرض
يلقي ولو واريد واحد ما وصلت للحرب
بس المشكله انه هذه الحرب جايه تصعب يوم
بعد يوم كل ما نكبر كل ما نستوعب انه عيب
نبكي وان احنا ما نقدر نضم راسنا اذا نخاف
هنا شريط ذكريات مئات الاطفال باخر يوم
بحياتهم بالمستشفى
واللي عرفته انه الشيء الوحيد اللي احتاجه
انه انا امن
الحياه
كلها نهايتها وحده
وكلنا ماشيين بالطريق نفسه الى نفس
النهايه ليش نخاف اكثر من ما نعيشها ليش
ممكن ليش نخاف اكثر من ما نعيش هالاطفال
اكثر من ما نعيش هالحياه
ليش ممكن نعطي قيمه للحياه وننسى اهم
لحظات اللي ممكن نعيشها ليش ما نعتبر كل
يوم نعيشه هو اخر يوم بحياتنا
ونعطي قيمه لكل لحظه تمر من خلاله
تعرفونها الطفله
13 سنه
هالطفله محبوسه بالبيت
ابوها يخاف يطلعها للشارع والناس تحكي
عليها
ابوها يخاف
انه جيرانها او اصدقائي يقولوا له بنتك
مخبله 14 سنه هالطفله طلعت قدام مئات
الناس ترسلهم رساله واحده
انك اعظم شيء ممكن تقدمه لابنك انك تامن
بيه ولا غير انك تجرح لجناح تزرع له جناح
صغير حتى يكون اعظم راقص باله
[تصفيق]
قبل اربع سنوات
فتحت اول مدرسه لذوي الهمم بالعراق كانت
اول مدرسه مجانيه بها حاليا 200 طفل
جاني طفل عمره 17 سنه جزء الايسر متوقف
بالكامل كان كل مره يلزم القلم يرجع يشمره
بالارض لان تتشنج ايده بس حلمي الوحيد انه
اقدر الزم القلم او ارسم شنو نحتاجهن
واحنا نفتح اصابيع واحد واحد ونبوس ايديها
منه من هذه الايد اللي كانت تتشنج
الى هذه اللوحات
[تصفيق]
الى معارض الرسم
الى المنصه حتى يكون عازف بهذه الايد
نفسها
يعزف لحن ولا واحد بينا ممكن يفتهمه بعد
مئات الدراسات اللي سويتها عن ذوي الهمم
بالعراق وصلت الى نتيجه واحده انه الشيء
الوحيد اللي ممكن يعالج ذوي الهمم انه
يامن ويطمن وينحب
[تصفيق]
لما تصاب اللوكيميا تحتاج تزرع نخاع
العمليه الاغلب العالم
لمده اربع سنوات اشتغلت كل الشغلات اللي
بالدنيا حتى اقدر اجمع مبلغ هذه العمليه
لاكبر ابنائي لما وصل وقتها راسلت 18
مستشفى حول العالم في سبيل انه ولو مستشفى
وحده تقبل تعالج هالطفل كل المستشفيات
كانت ترفض بعذر انه هذه الحاله هي اند
ستيج والمستشفى الاخيره كتبت الايميل
بحرقه قلب قلت لهم بدل المليون انا اعطي
عشره وبدل الكومنديشن من وزير انا رئيس
الوزراء كل اللي تريدوه انا ممكن اوفره
فالمستشفى ردت عليه بايميل واحد
[تصفيق]
هذه كانت اعظم رساله خلتني افتح المدارس
مجانا لان اعرف قيمه الحياه
حتى تكون عظيم بعين نفسك تحتاج انك توقف
لفئه مهمشه بالمجتمع تحتاج توقف لي في
العالم ناسيتها بكل وظيفه بالعالم لازم
دائما تفكر انك تقدم ولو خدمه واحده لشخص
واحد غير نفسك
كل الرسائل اللي وصلتني من خلال
الاكاديميه علمتني شغله واحده انه المناصب
العظيمه المزيفه هي عباره عن شي مؤقت ممكن
يتلاشى اما المنصب العظيم هو القيمه اللي
راح تقدر تزرعها بعيون طفل وبعيون اي شخص
تقدم له ولو خدمه واحده
[تصفيق]
بالنهايه
ادركت ادركت انه كل احنا ضعفاء
انه اقوى واحد قاعد قدامي هو ضعيف وممكن
اضعف من اطفالي
انه احنا نحلم مثلهم ونخاف مثلهم ونبكي
مثلهم بس حطينا روحنا باطاراتنا تعرف
حقيقتها
كنت اتمنى بس انه احنا نفكر مثلهم
العام
توفت بنيتنا الوسطانيه زبيده
فجيت لقيت صديقتها قالتله جوه الميز
قلتلها شنو صاير كانت انا ما اعرف يقولون
زبيده ماتت
يعني قاعد افكر انه انا هسه ما اقدر
اخابرها واطمن عليها ولا تجي تقعد يمي
بالصف حتى اقدر ابوسها واسلم عليها راح
تبقى عندي بس الفيديوهات ممكن اشوفها وهاي
[تصفيق]
رساله الوحيده الاخيره اللي بقت عندي
ديروا بالكم على نفسكم عدل وخلوا بالكم
دائما سؤال واحد بس
شنو قيمتنا وشنو سبب وجودنا على هذه الارض
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]